MICHEL DEGRAFF: So it
was very, I would say,
crucial for me to do this
interview in both English
and Creole, because I
see Creole languages,
even in the case of Haiti--
especially in the case
of Haiti--
as a particularly revealing
and clear test tube or case
study to really
show how language
can be such a powerful
tool either for domination
or for resistance, either for
oppression or for development.
So I would love teachers
who are watching this video
and will look at
the course to see
how they can adapt
the content in order
to address similar issues
in their own community,
because I think that
what you see happening
in the case of Creole languages
also happens in the US,
happens in Europe,
in Latin America,
in Africa, where
language is often
used as this technology for
domination or resistance.
And I think this course gives
some basic analytical tools
to be able to analyze
these patterns.
And for me, it's
also very important
that teachers in Haiti
and students in Haiti,
including, say, future
leaders or policymakers,
get to understand this
course and the readings
and to understand that
Haiti could do so much
better if teachers,
students, leaders
had this awareness of how
our attitudes towards Creole
versus French have played
over centuries in keeping
the country underdeveloped.
And if they could get a
better sense of the importance
of language in
education development,
then I think the country
would do so much better.
For me, it's a key
bottleneck that we
have to go past
in order to really
be able to develop
a nation, is to be
able to understand the
history and the nature
of your ancestral
language and to be
able to use it in a more
systematic and productive way.
If you cannot do that, there
is no way that you can develop
a whole nation that
speaks that language.